wikileaks founder julian assange has
been held in a high security prison
since he was arrested last spring at the
ecuadorian embassy in london where he
effectively was held for many years in
isolation
his extradition hearing is now finally
underway assange's lawyer
estimates he could face 175 years
in prison if he's extradited to the
united states he faces espionage charges
here
wikileaks exposed all kinds of things
some of which it was good to know
including corruption by the democratic
national committee
in 2016. so what is the story on julian
assange why is the doj pursuing this
case so aggressively
glenn greenwald has followed this from
the very beginning he's of course a
journalist founder of the intercept
and we're happy to have him tonight so
glenn um thanks for coming on
i think a lot of people have heard for
years that julian assange is a bad guy
who hurt the united states now the
united states
is going to bring justice in this case
what's your view of this tell us what we
should know
in three minutes about julian assange
let's remember tucker that the criminal
investigation into julian assange began
by the obama administration because in
2010
wikileaks published a slew of documents
none of which harmed
anybody not even the government claims
that that was very embarrassing to the
obama administration it revealed
all kinds of abuses and lies that they
were telling about these endless wars
that the pentagon and the cia are
determined to fight they were
embarrassing to hillary clinton
and so they conducted they initiated a
grand jury investigation to try and
prosecute him for reporting to the
public he worked with the new york times
the guardian
to publish very embarrassing information
about the endless war machine about the
neocons who are working in the obama
administration
to understand what's happening here we
can look at a very similar case which is
one that president trump recently raised
which is
the prosecution by the obama
administration as well of edward snowden
for the same reason that he
exposed the lies that james clapper told
he exposed how
there's this massive spying system that
the nsa and the cia control
that they can use against american
citizens and obviously this isn't coming
from president trump
he praised wikileaks in 2016 for
informing the public
he knows firsthand how these spying
systems that edward snowden exposed can
be abused and were abused in 2016.
this is coming from people who work in
the cia who work in the pentagon
who insist on endless war and who
believe that they're
a government unto themselves more
powerful than the president i
posted this week in a speech from dwight
eisenhower warning that this
military industrial complex what we now
call the deep state is becoming more
powerful than the president
chuck schumer warned right before
president obama president trump took
office
that president trump challenging the cia
was foolish because
they have many ways to get back at
anybody who impedes them
that's what these cases are about tucker
they're punishing julian assange and
trying to punish edward snowden
for informing the public about things
they have the right to know about the
obama administration they're basically
saying to president trump
you don't run the country even though
you were elected we do
and he's they're daring him to use his
pardon power
to put an end to these very abusive
prosecutions one which resulted in
eight years of punishment for julian
assange for telling the truth
the other one which resulted in seven
years of exile for edward snowden
of being in russia simply for informing
the public and embarrassing political
officials who are very powerful
so in 30 seconds the president could
pardon julian assange
right now and end this is that correct
he could have parted him and edward
snowden and there's widespread support
across the political spectrum
on both the right and the left for doing
both it would be politically
advantageous for the president the only
people who would be angry
would be susan rice john brennan jim
comey and james clapper because they're
the ones
who both of them exposed well that's
that's the most powerful summary i've
ever heard
of that story glenn greenwald thank you
very much for that